solve rich people problems they pay
better and if you solve rich people
problems they will make you one of them
when you solve rich people problems you
get to charge rich people prices part of
the reason that a 50 person is saying
well what exactly am I be getting if
somebody's got a hundred dollars in
their bank account you're asking for
fifty percent of their net worth so for
them it's a very important decision and
unfortunately this still might be half
the population doesn't mean necessarily
you should sell to them and to the same
degree that fifty thousand dollars might
have been less than one percent of that
other person's net worth so they just
didn't even care it would have been the
equivalent of trying to sell a dollar to
that person who's a hundred dollar in
their bank account you can only go to
zero like you'd only be so poor but you
can be infinitely Rich so your upside is
uncapped but your downside is zero and
so when you deal with rich people you
have unlimited upside which is why they
are better customers